[Music]
four weekends 800 participants and a
unique chance for europeans to
strengthen their democracy and help
shape the eu of tomorrow
it is really important to make the
voice of young people here in europe
because we are going to live in that
future
we are building right now
the conference on the future of europe
aims to give eu citizens a say in their
future
it's not just about improving the eu but
about coming up with new ideas
it's interesting to see the point of
views of different countries young
people elder people and to see how they
think about democracy
[Music]
they discussed how to make europe
greener safer and fairer and debated
ideas on everything from healthcare to
digitalization the economy to european
values
the climate crisis was also in the
spotlight
i've been part of a problem for climates
um
destroying the climate
and so i thought
it's time for me to change it's not
going to happen
overnight
but let's start the process for us this
weekend has started the process
participants spoke about the eu's role
in the world discussing topics like
trade humanitarian aid eu enlargement
asylum and migration
there's
one billion of people willing to come
tomorrow to european union if you just
open the borders
so that we have to to have some unified
policy about it
representatives will present their
panel's ideas to the conference plenary
to help shape the conference's
conclusions
they'll meet online for a second round
of deliberations in november and will
finalize their proposals in december and
january in cities around europe
the conference will deliver its
recommendations in spring
[Music]
you